by the way do you know how [ __ ] great
it is that a [ __ ] do you know how
great it is and how [ __ ] happy i am
for you that you [ __ ] came here in
this disgusting town yeah you [ __ ]
are a new york kid doing yeah yeah yeah
you pulled up in a bentley and i [ __ ]
got real happy i appreciate it i got
real [ __ ] happy thank you well you
know
are we on yeah yeah oh [ __ ] okay well
we're yeah we don't tell people oh okay
yeah no that's good well what's good
about me is that i'm at the comedy store
and i'm not in jail you know because
it's been rough for a few years out here
uh left and right people getting taken
out head shots um yeah i just wish i
lived at a time when you didn't know
smoking was bad for you
that's the time i wish i lived in
because
you know we know so much now that to do
certain things now you have to really
have a death wish which i don't have
but
you know i don't have that but back then
you could just enjoy a cigarette i saw
clips of like jackie gleas you could see
like when jackie gleason was on like
train carts and and they're just
drinking and smoking and there was no
there was no talking about it it was
just going to the club and having having
scotch and drinking cigarettes was was
it well there was you know there was a
thing
in that era where people really like
like fun
was a big deal
like having fun right like [ __ ] loose
right let loose yeah having fun we've
kind of
done away with that now yeah where like
there was there was the idea that you
could really enjoy yourself and that
part of your life
should be defined by your ability to
have fun right to let loose yeah well if
you know i mean i'm sure giannis has
told you giannis papas of course but i
my problem in my fighting with my wife
is that it's a little too much with me
right so if i did live in that time
probably it probably wouldn't have been
long lived yeah you know like i still i
mean i have two i i say i'm gonna have
two white claws i'm up all night
drinking yeah yeah yeah yeah
you just have fun i just have fun and
then let's smoke a cigar but paul is
three in the morning yeah you got to be
up with the kids tomorrow yeah i'm fine
and i'm an absolute mess for two days
yeah they should have those the kids and
then she has the kids and then she's
resentful to me oh by the way then i'm
going now i'm going to beverly hills for
a week yeah but she's not on netflix
you know what i mean like i'm the one
with the yeah
wake up a little bit you know are you
funny uh that's hilarious all right so
your netflix special's out what is the
title of it uh the netflix special is
called nocturnal admissions nocturnal
adventures missions right i like that
yes and uh yeah it's on netflix right
now it's streaming it's doing uh
extremely well so i'm very very uh
thankful about that that's awesome check
it out man it's getting great reviews
and i'm really happy i was working hard
and luckily i got covered early yeah
because getting you got covered like you
were like patient zero dude i i joked i
said i got covered like i was waiting
for an album to drop like i was online
at midnight for playstation yeah i got
covered and then you just basically like
coasted for the next two years like
unafraid and and yeah yeah and then you
were like you were like immunity who
gives a [ __ ] well yeah and then five
months after when the world was shut
down yeah i was like all right now let's
go to the states that really don't have
don't believe in coverage right so yeah
and that's what we did yeah we we we
went on tour that whole time i wonder to
be honest with you i wonder in our
lifetimes if there will ever be a more
interesting time to do stand-up than
when we did it
like during that era and i think me you
brett ernst yeah and maybe a couple of
other people were out like we were out
no no like i was like people were like
dude are you tour like is this your tour
we were out like it wasn't happening
yeah we were out like it didn't exist
yeah we were out i was in texas i was in
arizona all those 100 i was doing it
every week yeah and some comics were
like i see the i mean obviously i don't
think they were talking about who i
don't know who they're talking about
right but yeah these comics who have
like full schedules like yeah that's
responsible and it's like nobody's
booking you right you're not giving up
anything you're not yeah
went out early and they got sick
yeah and then they had to post hey if
you shook my hand in the meet and greet
and that was funny because it's like
what you did a [ __ ] meet and greet
like that was like that was like the
next level of like wait a minute what
so that made a lot of people start going
like what the [ __ ]
you're you're doing comedy and you're
doing a meet and greet but it was like
listen the way i looked at it was like
this listen i was like you know i've
done comedy now
i started in like 2010 like late 2010.
so i was like listen i'm doing a very
long time you're 13 years in 13 years
yeah i was like i finally have
some people that want to come see me
yeah i've been on the road a very very
long time
and i'm taking every precaution
and
just knowing a little bit about viruses
you knew
basically
you know this wasn't you there was no
way
yeah this was going to be preventable
if i mean people are going to get it
yeah people are going to get it you know
what i don't like dope now tim yeah is
that now they're coming out going the
truth is yeah the real truth is right if
it wasn't an n95 mask it kind of didn't
yeah like like it had a cloth it was
fake it was fantastic yeah
well remember the hand sanitizer
remember all the things we did wiping
down packages all that [ __ ] and then we
realized oh none of that worked that's
not how it spread we don't have to
[ __ ] wipe down all of this [ __ ] you
don't have to take out [ __ ] ethyl
alcohol and spray down it doesn't affect
food yeah panda express [ __ ] to go
boxes yeah we didn't have to do any of
that nobody
it was insane but we we were out there
and i remember doing stand-up the week
before
the election
and i and it was uh it was november and
it was the week before the election and
i remember
it was we had the pandemic and the
election and i remember saying to my
opener we were sitting in the back in
the green room and i said
and then trump i believe had gone he had
just got coveted i think you were in
nashville yeah and he was getting flown
in a helicopter yeah and and i don't
know when this was it was maybe it was
october yeah it was close to the
election yeah yeah and i said to my
opener i'm like
we could find out the president is
dead
in the middle of the show
i'm like we don't know what's going on
i'm like the president of the united
states yeah
who's in his 70s has coven yeah that's
true he's overweight in his 70s has
covid and we are sitting in the back
of
i don't know if it was stand up live in
phoenix i don't know where i was but
i said
we're like close to an election i'm like
there's never been a crazier time
in my memory to do stand-up comedy than
this period no it was we did it in a
time where when we talk about it yeah
and you tell people you're gonna go like
years and years yeah you got on stage
like during it right like at the height
of it right i was actually in arizona at
the height yeah it was like every other
table they had partitions people had
masks people are gonna go wait a minute
what we did shows outside yeah you know
how funny was when trump was like i was
fine yeah he was like it was great but
he you know when they put him i heard he
actually had a rough time yeah he said
when they put him on the plane am i
gonna go out like stan sharer who was a
friend of his who died with it
so you know he was like what the [ __ ]
and
it is one of those things where you know
it was weird because most people were
okay but then every now and then you
heard somebody that was like they got
really [ __ ] up you went wait what
sometimes it was somebody who you
wouldn't expect but we were out there
doing stand-up during that time that was
crazy we we did we were and i was
getting real busy and it started to get
weird because like not many people were
doing it and then right i asked myself i
was i said to my wife i was like is this
okay like right i [ __ ] like am i and
then i was like i told people listen
like i you know if you want to come out
like be safe like right there you know
and then like all the clubs had that
like gun that like did something with
the air yeah well she didn't know like i
i didn't know nobody knew what that was
you know
no one knew i mean no one knew these
comedy clubs are coming clubs are trying
everything they're the worst you know
they're infectious disease breeding
grounds right it's people close together
eating drinking and laughing hopefully
no but we're spraying stuff right yeah
everyone's fine we got lysol
everything's fine
yeah there's there's 300 here very close
but with the spray we're recycling the
air they said that and i go what is that
like when they said no we recycle the
air the air is new i didn't know what
that they didn't know what it was it was
just everybody they were just like
listen we need money that's another
thing
that's the other thing that people
forgot you know people needed money yeah
and people
you know
there were certainly there were benefits
for people that didn't have but there
were people who were like hey man i got
a family yeah i gotta feed people you
have two kids that's why i was gonna say
[ __ ] you yeah you know no kids but i
want money yeah yeah so i was like
listen if you come to the show you know
i don't know how many people i killed
with my tour someone
died from my tour
someone died no i have no way of knowing
i found out one guy got sick at mine
like that actually came back that got
yeah because i said i go if you guys
hear anything just let me know yeah one
guy got it and then like a week later i
didn't hear anything so he i guess he
made it i don't even want to know
how many people died from my door
a few people died
a few people died
people are gonna die
and you better crush that night no it's
you know i mean you you came out yeah
and but you could have died from going
to the grocery store
yeah so what are you gonna do
and i also think that there are some
people that were like look i know the
risk i'm not living like this that's why
i'm not living like this anymore so if
god forbid if god forbid something
happens i'm going to a comedy club to
laugh tonight and i'm done because i sat
in the house for months and i'm going to
see this guy who i like i'm sure a lot
of people did that a lot and they were
probably very republican yeah and they
were and they were good audiences
um
and to me i love like to me comedy is a
live sport it's meant to be seen live
like it's obviously it's great when it's
recorded it's great but to me being in
the room is is is the thing it's a
hundred percent true there were no so to
me there were no substitutions these
live stream shows that people were doing
the shows on zoom
all of these
you know whatever you know technological
innovation that allowed people to
perform
you know i just was like in stand up
it's got to be live yeah podcasting can
be what it is but stand-up's got to be
live so i didn't feel like there was any
substitution so i'm like i'm either
gonna not do it right for two years or i
gotta go out yeah yeah no i felt the
same way and i also was like being out
there i was able to work the special
more yes and in my mind i'm going wow
like if i can kind of duplicate what's
going on here yeah the night of the
special but yeah being there live and
having your fans see you in in your
element at your best running something
and they're there it's just better than
clips right clips are great
established titles is a project based on
historic scottish customs where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords or ladies in english they allow
people to buy as little as one square
foot of dedicated land so that they can
call themselves a lord or a lady they
are committed to planting a tree with
every order it is a fun
novel way to help preserve the
picturesque woodlands and biodiversity
of scotland
while supporting global
aforestation efforts we have i mean
really it's interesting
you know
title packs give you at least one square
foot of dedicated land on a private
estate in edelson scotland on an
official certificate with a crest your
certificate features a unique plot
number which you can see the exact
location of your land we plant a tree
with every order and work with global
charities one tree planted and trees
to support global reforestation efforts
it's a great last minute
gift you could officially change your
name to lord or lady and get it on your
credit card plane tickets etc you can
even get it on your dating profiles that
is baller
i mean that's pretty baller you get a
little square foot of land to scotland
and you could call yourself lord avery
wow
established titles told me the first 200
people purchasing a title pack using my
link will be effectively be next to my
plot
within a few minutes of walking distance
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or a lady we can build our
little tim dylan show kingdom
i mean i don't understand why you
wouldn't do this it makes an amazing
last minute gift established titles is
actually running a massive labor day
sale right now plus if you use the code
tim dillon you get an additional 10 off
i mean this sounds really fun right they
sent us our certificate it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool to be a lord i'm lord
dylan and you're you're lady avery
you're a lady
it's really interesting
that that this actually also helps the
environment yeah that's what's fun to me
you get a cool name it helps the
environment there's nothing there's
nowhere to go wrong here
it's just kind of fun to put it on the
credit card lord whatever yeah and it's
so hard to become a boss or get other
titles you're never gonna have another
title just take this title you can buy
it
the best things are things you can buy
the best accomplishments are things you
can buy and they plant a tree
go to
establishtitles.com tim dillon to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel establishtitles.com
tim dillon to get your gifts now and
help support the channel two out of
three men will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 35 more
than 50 million men in the us suffer
from male pattern baldness keebs has
more five-star reviews than any of its
competitors there are only two fda
approved medications that can prevent
hair loss keeps offers both keeps offers
a simple affordable and stress-free way
to keep your hair via convenient virtual
doctor consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave
your home 24 7 care and support keeps is
a network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goal a
reality it's low cost treatments start
at just 10 a month it keeps offers
generic versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss you
have a really good friend who's using
this and it's great
yeah it's it actually really worked well
steve says everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door and
discreet packaging and proven results
remember when prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast this is the
real way to do it you keep the hair you
have you don't use a wig you don't do
anything crazy you don't need surgery
i'm telling you if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
keps.com
tim dillon to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon to get your
first month free k-e-e-p ask.com
tim dillon
now as somebody who didn't grow up with
the internet now seeing what it is your
kids are growing up with it yeah right
yeah um how do you shield them from
it's crazier parts of it with the
it's everything from bullying to you
know god forbid you come you come home
one day and you're you see your
daughter's son and they're watching the
whitney cummings on the internet
what do you get
you know like how do you handle
as a father
how do you handle all this
no it's actually it's actually true well
not the whitney thing true um no like my
daughter's watching you know she said to
me the day she got dad can i get
tick-tock and i go absolutely not and
she's like but i'll just and this is
what let me know that it's [ __ ]
horrible right she goes no i'll just go
to the things that i want to see no dude
they're doing stuff they're doing gross
[ __ ] there's a lot of sexual [ __ ] up
there my daughter's ten man yeah you
know and there's problems and the kids
are locked in the phones big man my son
is you know my son is he does watch a
lot of basketball stuff and youtube
stuff but my son has got his head down a
lot right to the point where i'm like
buddy buddy i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] talking
to you like my dad that didn't happen
with us no you know we stared at the
window and
yeah no there was nothing to stare at
other than your life
yeah you had to kind of live in what was
yeah in in in in they're happier than i
than than we were oh the kids yeah yeah
they're happier and yeah they're right
yeah they seem happier my kids are happy
my kids are happy they're just
distracted but i don't want them i'm
fighting it i'm i'm fighting it so
you're gonna find out do you think you
get worn down eventually do you think it
breaks down like
when they get into the teen years
because all of their friends are gonna
be doing this
so at what point do you
i don't know do you give in or do you
how does it work
well here's the thing you know the i
think the italian in me i i kind of i
kind of bribe right cash is cash is king
in the house right so i told my daughter
my daughter was on the couch he'll love
this yeah
uh my daughter's on a couch with stacey
and she goes i want an iphone and you
know stacy goes well lucas got an iphone
after fifth grade you gotta wait till
after fifth grade right she goes but i'm
different than lucas i want an iphone so
her soccer team didn't win a game oh
yeah and they scored one goal all season
it was terrible they never won we would
travel to yonkers we would travel to
dobbs festivals just to be embarrassed
seven o'clock in the morning there's dew
all over the thing i'm exhausted i'm
yelling at my wife why i had to get up
so early i got coffee in my hand and
they get blown out we get back in the
car
yeah right get in the car and we would
just wouldn't talk about the game we'd
go get lunch right so
uh they score one goal all year it's the
last game they haven't won a game so i
just out of nowhere i go sophia
you score a goal tomorrow morning you
score a goal again tomorrow morning get
you an iphone 11 whatever it was first
first half she's dragging ass all the
kids are right yeah it's all over
they're losing the money stays in my
pocket money stays them up and now
parents start hearing about it the
parents there's rumblings yeah hey dude
versi just [ __ ] versy told sophia you
know we're losing dude second half
starts she starts running the ball
ricochets it's in front of her it's just
her and the goalie she lofts it up over
the goalie's head it goes in all the
parents start going nuts everyone sophia
is running down in the middle of the
game tim middle of the game she goes dad
iphone 11. and everybody [ __ ] went
nuts but you know i'm telling my kid
listen some people don't like the parent
i tell my kid you scored 20 tonight
you're gonna get cash right you know i
said you get honor roll you're getting
300 cash and we're going to go get you
the sneakers no it's smart do you ever
when the when the team's not doing good
you ever grab the coach and go like what
are we doing here
you know what i mean like do you ever
grab the coach you're like listen up
seven weeks in a row and nothing's
changed like are we do you have a plan
do we have any plan as to how to get out
of this like
you know like they had a game in queens
by randall's island yeah a team that
never loses yeah and
we actually had the decency to just
cancel it
[Laughter]
no the parents had a meeting and they go
we're not driving we're not all driving
down to queens to get to do that so
let's just let's forfeit now so we could
go out and drink tonight and they and
the parents did they canceled it there
were two types of parents sports parents
when i was coming up there was the
parents who
didn't care where they were just like
this is a babysitter
these three hours a week that you're
gone are three hours i don't have to see
you yeah and then there were parents who
would physically attack the coach and
referee if they didn't like the calls
yeah yeah like it was those two extremes
and very few in the middle it was either
like hey have fun we don't really care
yeah the other extreme was that you know
there are literally if you google this
ben yeah yeah there was and these were
like connected guys in long island
everybody thinks they're connected it's
you know yeah um they went down
two guys attacked a baseball co a
baseball coach long island they went on
to the field
they literally were like what the [ __ ]
going on
and they um
yeah right there right here in 2007.
brothers busted for a beat down of long
island
baseball coach and it was like a uh i
remember this in in in 2007
and basically it was like an 11 year old
baseball player
upset over being benched
uh for cursing and batting practice
called his father who drove to the
bellmore ball field rushed the mound
with his brother
pummeled the coach
sending him to the hospital
police said wednesday
the brothers frank basile and roger
bastille who own a restaurant i love
called hudson and mccoy or used to we're
arrested and charged i think they do it
was a great i used to enjoy it
um
they were arrested in charge of tuesday
this was years and years ago
with whatever
you know how funny is that when they're
in the holding cell yeah what did you
get i was doing dope no no i beat the
[ __ ] out of a little league yeah we
[ __ ] up just keep my kids couch
and you know because their sons get they
benched them for being like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like you have to be on the
bench no there was there was another one
where the parents go come on and the and
the guy the guy goes uh if you do one
more thing and he just left he he left
he took the mask off and the ump just
left i'm not no we don't you know right
i don't uh i don't do that yeah
in long island it happens
100 percent all that like what people do
for children sports is insane yeah and
it's such and all it is is a projection
of their of what's going on with them
which is right because they regret maybe
they go maybe they're trying to relive
their glory days or they never they
regret you know not their parents didn't
push them more
yeah and they're like maybe if i push
the kids we can get them there was a guy
i think in our district or in the town
over he eight eight year olds he kicked
a soccer ball say go get it [ __ ] it
freaked out he was just never he was
banned from the field he wasn't allowed
not he wasn't allowed on the property
he wasn't allowed to be seen he wasn't
allowed to be seen on the property like
they were just like this guy can't even
like not only
not only are you not doing this anymore
like you can't be seen people can't see
you anymore
so what was he doing he was just telling
eight-year-olds
he was uh i guess i guess uh he was just
telling eight-year-olds something and
they weren't listening and i guess he
just had a breaking point of losing yeah
you know because there's only so much
you could take do you ever no do you
coach no no i don't know but if i but
like one time i ran like intramurals
yeah where they broke up the our our
whole team and yeah and i did and the
kids like you know i know like i could
tell a kid that like is just going
through it like takes it real seriously
where i'll be like dude just go you know
like i was able to read these guys want
to win for them right not the kid right
so this guy probably my guess is he
probably lost 13 weeks in a row you know
you know his wife is saying something
right i've seen wives actually like go
up to the husband while they're coaching
and be like can you do something can you
do something yeah interesting you know
because they're at breakfast and he's
yelling and she's like why don't you win
a [ __ ] game you don't think he's
taking that in the car that's
competitive he's getting in the car go
i'm thinking like this so um this kid
kicked the ball i think i heard he
kicked a soccer ball i don't know what
the [ __ ] it was he kicked a soccer ball
far and started saying you get it you
[ __ ] like it was like and people were
like yeah he's just never coming back
you know
jesus yeah and then but then that guy
shows up like
yeah to the auditorium for the school
play yeah everybody's like yeah hey
harry there he is and you you have a
tight-knit community of people who know
each other well ours yeah so there's
surrounding towns but are exactly like
other people it's real small schools
might as well be private right right and
that's what i want i want to be away
from people yeah you know and i just
want to be why i want to be i want to be
in a rich country town yeah with horses
have you been to new york city have you
[ __ ] dude new york city is [ __ ] and i
hate saying that that's your home city
that's my city that's right that's where
i got my chops with stand up that's
where you got your chops with stand up
that's right that's where i got my chops
mutton chop at keene's
many chops no chops
lots of chops uh and to see what it is
now dude to go down there like i was
telling you earlier like taking my son
to a game and seeing the amount of
homeless and and the hustlers and stuff
down and my kids are scared and then i'm
thinking what's somebody's breaking
point yeah right like you get so i saw
what happened in in austin texas i saw
it happen i saw a guy track you know he
got somebody told him no he tried to
jump in front of a car so now you're you
know wait a minute this is crazy to me
because this is the most beautiful city
in the world austin texas you saw
somebody i just saw some guy have a
breaking point and start yelling and
screaming and freaking out because so so
that's when the true homeless guy and i
think that that's what happens on the
trains and the subways in new york city
you know in the subways in new york city
somebody's there that whole day they
were shut down they were said [ __ ] you
who knows what happened they're sitting
there and then they see a guy you know
laughing with their kids in yankee
jerseys right and he goes they're
they're getting into a jaguar tonight
going back up to westchester yeah and
somebody gets you know what i mean
people have breaking points i don't want
to be there with my family when that
happens right no that makes a lot of
sense and westchester's incredible you
know it's good schools and stuff like
that so yeah i don't know i hope that
doesn't sound like a snooty [ __ ] i'm
just saying like no you know i worked in
a certain place where you know to a
level where i want my kids to have a
nice you want your family to be safe
there's nothing stupid about that it's
about safety man yeah you know it's
about my kids being safe and my kids
feeling safe i have specified now this
sounds sturdy i don't want to live near
people who fly on public airways yeah
like anyone that flies public i want to
live fly commercial i really don't want
to live
yeah near anyone that flies like a
commercial air yeah not public
commercial but i consider it it's like a
public it might as well be
i want to live near people it's the
level of here's how rich
the areas are that i want to live in no
one's even home yeah you know how rich
that is where it's no one's really even
home ever it's because
it's not a community yeah it's just a
money it's money laundering
and with security yeah it's like the
mossad like the security is like saudi
secret service crazy rich just things
that are blinking and it's white-collar
crime while they're summer in paris
that's right that you know that that's
the area and i've always liked that
since i'm a kid since i'm a kid i've
always liked those areas it's not
because i have money now when i was a
little kid i always liked
those areas where people were so so rich
it was confusing well you know
you know what's funny and me and you
have that me and you have this in common
because we've talked about it for a long
time yeah it's like and and all my
friends and comedy make fun of me like
you like a [ __ ] like you like a good
restaurant yeah i like i like
tops yes like i want to i want to get i
want to fly private one day that's my i
want to fly privately i don't fly
private but i like to be around those
who do it's a waste of money you're
close though you're going to you're a
waste of money it's a yeah but you know
what it's it's necessary i think yeah
yeah i heard ron white said that
somebody goes yeah why do you do that
why do you waste time he goes man it's
so good yeah you know it is good you
know it's nice to just have your own but
it's nice to you know to to
to to be in a
and i think we shouldn't pretend
that
that's not desirable well see what i do
is i fly first and can't afford it
always yeah but i still do it i fly
first that will be the last luxury i
give up if everything collapses on me i
will i will sell the bentley i don't
care i will never go back to coach i
won't fly yeah i just will drive to gigs
like i don't like you're never going in
the back of the plane once you get to
first it's i can't go to the back it's
almost insulting it's almost insulting
how it's different yeah how different i
was gonna do a bit on it and then i said
somebody had to do this bit and then
seven minutes and 40 something seconds
or seven years between brian regan who's
[ __ ] i think one i mean he's just one
of matt rush one of the greatest of all
time and and you know he's a friend dude
he's the nicest guy
this guy did from getting to your gate
yeah to getting on the plane to first
class versus coach it's you're crying
laughing but yeah after you sit in coach
like i i now i sometimes if i can't
afford it because they'll be like hey
you know it's it's an extra thousand
then i'll be like all right i'll go to
business yeah stacy will kill me right
now because when i go to cities i buy
sneakers right right now you're you're a
problem with spending some time
you like to treat yourself well oh yeah
i uh
uh build a hat a new hat every now and
then billboard pete davidson i just all
we want versus to get rich because we'll
see what he does yeah i told my wife i
want a horse i want a horse you will
dress like these hypebeasts out here you
have like a two thousand dollar hoodie
no tim you're gonna come to my house and
see if you're sitting on a white horse
yeah i i really want like i want you to
feed it by the way italians when
italians succeed this is what they do
yeah like an exotic animal i get that
white white things and i want one
weird cat yeah
yeah dude how funny you said that i was
actually asking stacey if she wanted to
get a lynx yeah yeah yeah no no i want
white marble everywhere yeah white
marble everywhere fish tank guys
little fish tanks
giannis redid his basement yeah and when
you sit on janus's couch downstairs to
the to the left yeah you can see and
it's all white marble and i stare at it
like like a fly to a light i just i
can't get my eyes off of it yeah i see
white marble in stone that's another
thing we love stone yeah i love stone
white stone for me it's amazing anything
white like when you pulled up in your
car and i i just
i saw like uh the b on the white i
couldn't believe it yes like you know
yeah it was a pleasure to just get in
something right yes that's right yeah so
this will be clipped and it will be used
on
neo-nazi websites yeah by the way
by the way we're saying white leather
and white
marbles don't yeah
yeah yeah yeah like yeah like i realize
when i go yeah i go everything white
yeah and then you're laughing
somebody could literally yeah that's
just gonna be i'm talking about yeah the
materials but yes um yeah no i i really
i really love being you know in sitting
in a situation like you know like i had
to fly business i flew first when i went
to uh grand rapids but on the way out
here i was in business and you know i
hit the guy's elbow yeah a little bit
and i was like i just can't do this
anymore right you know stacy watches
stacy sees the card though yeah we got
into it we got him we got into a thing
and i go i go look you know i'm making
i'm not making a ton ton of money but i
said i'm making a little
and she says listen you've got to reign
it in and she goes listen paul you know
so we got yeah like you got the llc
right she goes you know i gotta can she
goes she actually said to me she goes
can we have a talk tonight yeah because
we really need to talk and she goes can
i just can i just be in charge of the
money and i go look just just you know
i'm making them like let's talk let's
talk about it and she goes paul you
please for me she goes this might be a
big problem for us
she's like because my wife saw the
foresight was this could be divorced
right so like this could be because
you're gonna go out and you're gonna buy
three pairs of jordans right and you're
gonna buy first class right and then and
it's great but like we have we have
children that need to get educated yeah
so you gotta watch that and you gotta be
careful so she looks at it so like you
know today for example i pulled it to
you know i went to the i went to the
mall
i got you know i got some press coming
up i got some tv coming up this week out
here so you know you got to treat
yourself i bought a new pair of jordans
and i said but then i walked past
another sneaker store i bought another
pair really but here's the thing i got
to send them home i can't pack them i
don't have enough so i'm buying sneakers
and i've got to ship them all so you
have two pairs of jordans on this trip
that you're shipping home now i have
five pairs of sneakers on this trip
i got listen to this i have a i have
it's actually crazy like i'm here for
four days
it's crazy
yeah like yeah so i got yeah so i i have
them and my you're gonna really laugh my
uh luggage has a section for the actual
sneaker boxes i don't doubt it yeah so i
got the sneakers but then i'm going
through and i see jordan so i get them
then i i saw another pair but stacy was
watching it would have another pair
would have been another 500 after i
already spent like six on two pairs so
she'll just go so what did you do she
knows she'll question me how was your
day how was your friend do you do cash
so she doesn't know i mean yeah i mean
sometimes i'll throw a little cash or
yeah what did you you know how was the
trip the her way to start is how was the
trip how was your flight right you know
when how was your flight was like what
did you did you spend right another
thing that changed my life was the delta
sky club changed my life yeah you go to
delta sky club i've never been there you
know here's here's the thing i got to be
honest with you i got to be honest with
you you americans you know
we had the british airways lounge in
london and like how was that we went to
the qantas lounge in australia here's
the reality american lounges just don't
come they don't compete no you know what
the food i was a little disappointed in
the food at delta they had like one
little hot thing yeah no dude the qantas
lounge that business lounge it's great
it's the best it was so good and then
the virgin lounge too and yeah some of
the best coffee i've ever had oh dude
the coffee the hot cold dishes uh they
make uh grilled cheeses for you like
paninis and stuff they make real cheeses
they call them a toasties
uh soup yeah you know nice rainy day
with the soup i mean you know so i i i
respect the delta sky club no this guy
the sky club like was something where we
fly enough where it's worth it a
thousand times worse but i agree i i
heard some of the delta ones in the
country are like exceptional yeah but
the ones that i went i've been to a
couple and i could have you know to be
honest it could have been a little
better food wise yes it is nice to sit
listen it's nice have unlimited you know
what's great i mean that's the other
thing about first class is you get a
meal and the meal is good yeah and the
meal in the back you know i i i is
atrocious and like
that's the other thing in in when you
are in coach you are sitting next to
people
who are diseased
you know like
i mean like openly like because it takes
it takes nothing to be in coach and i've
been in coach and i've been that person
who's diseased like i've gotten on coach
blowing my nose like on the way to
hilarities in cleveland for a weekend
blowing my nose like
my clothes are in like a ratty backpack
oh you're
immune systems worse i'm making twelve
hundred dollars for 17 shows in
cleveland like
it's a nightmare i bring food that i'm
eating like i've been that person and
now and so i know who that person is and
i don't want to be anywhere near them
you don't want to
do you ever look at the people on the
line for food when you go to the sky
lounge you just start laughing
you know what it is i i try to like
sometimes when they walk on a plane to
go back to coach i bless my i bless
myself
i go into silent prayer
for them and i go that's why i ask god
bless
i hope you know oh yeah no it's uh but
you know what feels bad what feels bad
is if you if you do first a lot yeah but
then like i said they were just like
paul it bumped a thousand do you still
want to do it and that was like and i
was like with what i was spending i said
no but then walking then when when you
fly first a lot but then you walk past
it because you're not in it anymore no
there's like a feeling of like i did it
one time you know he sits where do you
sit every time in coach you see every
time you coach and every time you pass
me right that's right i always pass it
and what do i do i always give you the
you point you literally point back
back what you purposely like you just
wanna that's like your wife or like
that's just well no he we're not
spending the business pays for his
travel when he comes to new york and
stuff we're not paying you guys don't
support him at first are you mentally
ill
this is good turn around turn around
turn around look at that turn around
look at yourself
whose name is on the show right there
is this
is this the group show
does that say saturday night live with
65 people in it is this an ensemble cast
oh he is a very nice guy i mean he has a
very nice life he does very well
i mean you know do you you rarely pay
for dinner that's true you know you're
very good to me you've been he's been to
the greatest restaurants in the world in
the world in london
nobu in malibu he goes in new york we
take him to dynamics when they you treat
eating like that's what i notice about
you that's what i respect you treat
eating yeah and foods and restaurants
and seafood you do that the way i would
say that like i would do either certain
sneakers or yeah i mean listen i love a
good meal like that but you need like
the like you need meal wise you want the
best right because i used to do drugs
and i miss drugs and i really like drugs
so it's an addictive it's an addictive
personality addictive thing to just say
i want this thing that's hard to get in
and i don't know that we'll be able to
get it and it just reminds me of drugs
because drugs was like oh can we get the
eight ball tonight
yeah i want the good eight ball we want
the pink rock you know the one that's
kind of
uh how do we get that well we gotta call
him we gotta drive to [ __ ] bayside
whatever and
this like to me i like to try to get
into the the best place because it's a
challenge so whatever yeah so it's like
you'd want a seafood tower that like
prince loved yeah that was delicious
yeah great and that was that's your
eight ball i want the last thing michael
jackson ate yeah
i want the last sushi piece of nigiri he
had before he went into a propofol coma
because what's life about who cares why
you know i'll be honest with you i was
on that [ __ ] and that's the greatest
there's nothing there's nothing better
that's better than come and as when you
come out of it yeah you're there's no
mood better right and if anyone
listening right now if you can get your
hands on
who's sponsoring our show propofol
but uh but he did that like he did that
like to sleep and [ __ ] which is wild
yeah
where do you stand on the michael
jackson thing i've never i've never
researched it but i i i i i i know it's
a hot button but we stumbled into it i
can't i can't watch it i can't listen to
music
i just can't listen to his music now
knowing like somebody told you somebody
that i like and trust right i go what
was the real that's the other thing i
was talking about that on another
podcast today when i watch true crime
when little kids are involved in yeah i
can't watch when i get anything with
kids i can't i hate true crime you know
why because women have made so much
money on it well women love it and i
mean these these people that make so
much money on it but when kids are
immoral it's my favorite murder all
these podcasts and it's immoral they're
exploiting the deaths of people for
money
they're sick these women are they not
oh um yeah no when it comes to children
i can't [ __ ] with it i think just having
kids hearing it but people that i i know
love trust were like dude i saw that i
saw that documentary and it's just like
it's a wrap what's the bad one
because there's a few docs but there's
one that's like not good no the one that
the wreath the most recent ones
something neverland or finding that no
that's the movie is finding neverland a
movie i don't think so uh no no i think
it's that one did they make another one
already dude it's like
some of the things that you leaving
neverland yeah that's finding neverland
is a movie and finding neverland we're
just confused about leaving neverland
and so now this is like kind of
indisputable
it's some of the things that were said
by multiple people kind of matching
stories and certain things like that and
what's worse is the parent from what
i've heard again i haven't seen it so i
don't want to talk too much about like
the parents were like he would he would
be like hey can i have your kid for half
a year
who are these parents yeah that's the
other thing right
that's
odd
well i think money's involved i think i
think it's like i mean how sick i mean
that's crazy you know i said i love
money you know what i mean i wouldn't
sell him and i barely know him i
wouldn't give him to michael jackson for
half a year he'd love it because he
wouldn't have to work and he could go on
the rise and again i i didn't
i'd
i i didn't see it yeah i don't know
exactly like what but i know that he
would like ask for a lot of time with
these kids and like some parents would
oblige and and dude that's like you know
that's [ __ ] up and it's insane [ __ ]
up i can't like get into a michael
jackson so i mean the guy is as far as
an artist he's incredible yeah and like
now i'm listening and like you can't
listen to that and not think of that i
know yeah you know like and woody allen
kind of similar but woody allen's got
some of the funniest
new york movies ever and you know but
that documentary now i can still watch a
woody allen movie and say that's really
funny but i got to be honest it is you
know that documentary is kind of damning
dude if you're obsessing over a 10 year
old and you're like a grown man it's
just there's it's hard to get into a
problem it doesn't matter like you know
cosby it's like oh he was a great
community told a great story okay he
also drugged and you know did [ __ ] to
women for 30 [ __ ] it's like right
it's like so it so for me um you know i
i can't listen to what that's what so
where i stand on it is like i don't know
everything right but i can't list i
can't get into it dude yeah and that's
an interesting conversation about like
the behavior of somebody versus their
material like what they put out right
now because it can ruin it
now you can separate the art from the
artist but it also
can be a thing where like if somebody
does something heinous yeah it's very
hard yeah to go oh but i can still rock
out to this song
i can't it's just it's hard yeah and
you're a father and the whole thing it's
tough what do you think djs do
they play yeah they'll they'll they play
they play it oh they play yeah i mean i
don't know any djs because i'm
successful yeah
i don't know so no i'm kidding i i mean
the big djs i'm not successful enough to
be friends with them and then the little
dj's that's actually interesting oh your
level's a dj yeah yeah yeah no no it is
i
i can't
like i can't like i can't hang out with
dj palette right cause i'm not that
level i would love to right he's gonna
hang out with andrew schultz first yeah
on his decline i may get khalid
but
i but little dj but a guy dj in a
wedding i don't know them yeah because i
hate like a lot of my friends growing up
with dj's it just it's just uh a lot of
long island dj's yeah it's a lot of long
island djs that are just gross
you ever talk to a dj it's disgusting
like the things they have to talk about
i mean it's just i talked to a dj once
at a show and he goes listen dude
anytime you want a mixtape dude i do all
this stuff from the yeah
yeah i mean and i was just like yeah
dude i'm good dude i'm like nice to meet
you though like that's all the best but
like no immediately after you hear that
i go i i'm done with your profession
like i don't want to hear it
i don't want to hear anything anymore
about anybody
that you do
but i think djs just play it and go i
don't know maybe they don't it really
depends it's a pet yeah i mean it also
depends like if it's like a bar mitzvah
for a 16 year old you shouldn't you know
yeah there should be things off the list
right i agree i agree with you there you
know wait is almost over
a new football season is about to begin
get ready for the nfl week one auction
with draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl to
celebrate the return of football
draftkings is giving new customers i
can't miss offer that just five dollars
on any football game and get 200 in free
bets instantly want more action for
opening night everyone can experience
the thrill of draftkings early win
promotion get up to seven you win bet on
any nfl team of your choice and if your
team leads by seven points at any point
during the game you get paid instantly
that's crazy
even if your team loses if they're just
up by seven you get paid how cool is
that yeah jeff kings is safe secure and
reliable best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want
that's the key right that's the key
that's the key because a lot of these
things they don't do that they don't
draftkings does though download the
draftking sportsbook app now and use
promo code tim dillon to get 200 in free
bets instantly when you place a five
dollar bat on any football game that's
called tim dillon only at draftking
sports book it's a great way to support
our show and have some fun and as an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl minimum age and eliability
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details if you
or someone you know has a gambling
problem crisis counseling and referral
services can be accessed by calling
1-800 gambler that's 1-800 gambler oh
and you know i love betting on sports i
love watching sports i've been using
this draftkings is great everybody loves
me undies it's the best underwear on the
market it's buttery soft and sustainable
undies bralettes and socks
that uh really make your booty and your
whole body feel happy with items
designed to make your life more
comfortable
let your skin sing a song of joy with
meundies socks bralettes
as they feel like they're spun from silk
and clouds guaranteed to be the softest
stuff you've ever felt in your life
their signature micro modal fabric is
sustainable breathable and stretchy as
hack available in sizes extra small to
4xl they have new colors and prints
dropping weekly so there's always
something exciting to check out
try their free to join membership for
free shipping on every order in excel
which has exclusive perks like an item
shipped to your door try their free to
join membership for free shipping on
every order and exclusive perks like an
item shipped to your door every month
secret sales and early access to their
newest stuff the undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 20 off
plus free shipping and returns
20 off plus free shipping and returns to
get 20 off your first order and free
shipping and a 100 satisfaction
guarantee go to meundies.com
that's meundies.com
tim i'm wearing them right now
great how do you think about the the the
comedy now
uh
people do do you think that people are
kind of you know
times are getting real now the economy's
tough they're you know we've had issues
russia china all these things um do you
think the
kind of virtue signaling
for lack of a better word like
woke stuff people are just getting a
little bored and they go we just want to
go back to laughing i i real [ __ ] i
think that the i think that the woke
thing is starting to i got a netflix
yeah i got a nestle right
you know but no and and and you know
what and shout out to netflix because
they saw it and i and i didn't know yeah
after they saw it they were like hey you
know what
they're putting mine on
yeah we've said some stuff and and this
belongs here because it's funny and all
the other stuff that's a big sign and
you're talking about the biggest
streaming you know platform the best
stream platform so many people have
saying you know what you know and
another thing i loved tim was the way
they defended chappelle and ricky
gervais like to come out and go look
guys these are jokes and if you're gonna
pick it and [ __ ] like that then you
could get another like them saying that
is a huge well not only i don't even
know if you knew this they had there was
a trans woman working for
netflix who was very upset about these
specials and like a bunch of the other
employees just threw out the window like
in downtown hollywood
she was like on twitter trying to get
stuff going they threw her right out the
window they opened the door because
netflix ted cerando's came in you ever
seen that scene in casino where he goes
open the door with her hand
open
sometimes when you work in an
environment you have to do those things
now so so let me ask you now you are on
the road all the time people um
can see you i just wanna i was like in
the middle of the episode let people
know where where they can find your live
dates because you're one of the best
live performers out there to go see you
i really appreciate it it's it's uh
we're working with paulversie.com it's
the easiest thing in the world yeah
p-a-u-l-v-i-r-z-i.com
and just go to his website yeah and let
people know so you're going to london in
october i'm doing my first ever lunch
that's [ __ ] awesome so the new york
giants who i'm a fan of are playing the
packers in london nfl does the london
game every year the giants are playing
there talk to my agent and i go hey i
got some fans in the uk saying how come
you haven't been out here let's do
something so i'm taking my family yeah
and then uh then we're gonna go to paris
or italy afterwards that's amazing you
know so we're gonna yeah so i'm gonna go
out do a show out there in in london and
uh i'm looking forward to it man go to
the giants game and
we loved it didn't you love it oh i
loved it it was the best really loved it
we loved it man i went to ireland yeah
scotland ireland and london dublin was
amazing
uh london was so amazing that
uh and and all of those places um but
london there's a special spot
in my heart for london i love doing you
actually said this a long time ago like
go to like places and do one-off like i
remember at the pandemic you were doing
like one-house but i'm doing on october
19th i'm doing the dc improv
20th i'm doing a philly punch line i
want to do smaller like we did that
theater tour was amazing but like to
create new stuff and to experiment i i
want to do smaller places like i've been
doing these improvs and they're big
improvs and they're great and we have a
lot of fun with them yeah but to really
try new stuff and experiment yeah you
got to go to smaller places dude i was
just at this place called the listening
room in grand rapids yeah it's like 200
you look like
it was the greatest the stage is big
enough where you could do your thing but
they're right there it's it they're
great like i love rooms like that that
is where i you know we all came up in
those rooms those are the rooms i think
because you know the next hour i want to
do i do a lot of topical stuff in this
hour because it all came from this
podcast and it came from this crazy time
that we lived through yeah and a lot of
it was you know also
married into
my family stuff and everything but the
next hour i want to do i want to stay
away from topical and i want to go just
do stand-up jokes or like
i just want to do like i want to take
this book i'm writing called the boomer
guide to parenting about my parents and
how i grew up and i want to take people
on a journey how 90s kids grew up and
the insanity and the horrible food we
ate and the craziness and like how
hilarious and detached our parents were
and aloof they were
that's my goal for the next hour wow and
that's dope but that is i got to do that
i think outside of traditional comedy
clubs
i think or maybe really good comedy
clubs and and yeah and if i'm being
honest i think somebody like you yeah i
think somebody seeing somebody like you
do that yeah and really bring that into
something is a whole other thing because
i want to get super personal in that
world because and as i'm trying to write
this book now i'm realizing i'm like
there's so much funny stuff there that i
want to do
and have it be completely different from
this show because this show is is our
late night show it's like our topical
sure every week we do
for the most part topical
jokes and we love it sure it's what i
grew up watching letterman or whatever
but then with the stand-up i want to
move into that arena where it's kind of
like i want to go back to
some more of that when i first started
where i was like mining the depths of my
experience for funny [ __ ] yeah that's
that's awesome and if i can that's no of
course you can and like i'll be back
talking about hunter biden's dick for
money right bob
hey hope you guys
[Laughter]
hunter biden's on crack
but yeah i mean because i feel like with
stand-up it's like one of the hardest
things about it
is like you know these masters right you
watch bill burr you watch these people
that have been at it forever and they're
amazing and they're the top gold you
know standard mount rushmore
and you go they just had to keep getting
better and sharper and it's
not easy but everybody that you just
mentioned everybody that you just
mentioned took the road of sticking with
it going the long way and just like
really going out there honing it being
able to it's like you said you see
somebody live right and it's like going
on these tour dates and all these things
i'm doing like crowd work is it and then
finding out how to do a bit and and but
your thing is like you're you're
you're so good at what you do and you're
such a your mind is so good at this that
if you shift that to your personal [ __ ]
yeah that's coming too like it's because
that's why you are but but what you do
is you you're focusing on you know
hunter biden's got a crack pipe on his
dick right you do this show you're gonna
talk about that yes but if you go to the
other thing that's going to and it's
funny that you said about the growing up
in the 90s because i grew up in the 90s
like hip-hop era you know and and dude i
i remember like coming up in the early
two times like i if i wrote a book i'm
like trying to think of things i would
yeah i door knocked in queens at dinner
time for phone cable and internet right
it's me knocking on your door oh hey
guys i'm in the i smell the food
i smell the food yeah and i'm going hey
what's your can i see your cable bill
and it was like you know i almost got
killed but then there were times where i
got sales but you start thinking of
things like that that you did and you're
going like it was wild in new york in
that time oh growing up man for sure
well that's kind of what i want to do
and it's not easy
to do that being said um
that's the next iteration do you when
you look at your when you look at the
next hour or the next thing you're
looking to do
um how do you plan it out do you go i'm
just gonna go out there
raw
do you go i'm gonna have a thought do
you go how does it work i've i've
learned now after the third hour because
i did i did my album and then i did the
comedy central special and now this one
and a lot of the amazing write-ups which
i'm really humbled by were like he's
really him like really found like i'll
i'll go just on stage now and just talk
about
just if i think it i'm just going to go
out there and talk about it and build it
right you know like for example i was in
grand rapids and like you know all these
pilots are young now young dude right
and i don't like that no i don't like
that [ __ ] i actually look at my pilot
who's flying it's a big deal to me
because i got over a phobia flying and
you know this kid i mean this kid tim
this kid looked like he was intense i'm
not joking around i couldn't believe the
kid was actually going to get in an
aircraft and fly this many people
because he looked like he was in 10th
grade he had a baby face you know his
[ __ ] shirt was wrinkled right you
know and so i just go on stage and i'll
just and listen if it doesn't but i feel
like the way that i can construct a joke
or say things like that i'll go and talk
about that and start to get beats with
that yeah and maybe punch lines with
that and if you know i'm just doing i'm
trusting myself now yeah you know and
and really big on able to recognize when
something in life happens yeah that
when you're coming up you don't
recognize it yeah like like in nocturnal
emissions the the last joke my closer is
me and my son playing basketball and he
challenges me and he curses at me and he
gets in my face and everybody loves
loves the joke yeah but i knew in that
moment when that happened i was like wow
if i can incorporate this i can see it
now i'm better right if that makes sense
no
as life is coming at you when you live
it you could see it yeah for sure we're
trying to we're
there's so much interesting stuff out
there and the way the business is
changing what louis c.k just did was
pretty amazing
making his own movie yeah and releasing
it and that's something that we're
looking to do when we figure out how
exactly to do it um that dude's first to
a lot he was on the internet early
selling a special
he was early on a lot because when
you're that talented i think you also
are part of that comes from just having
the capacity the mental capacity to take
in a lot of information yeah and i think
when you're taking in a lot of
information
um you're utilizing a percentage of it
right yeah so i think when he takes in
all this info about like where things
are going yep and what technology is
allowing people to do he's applying it
to his life and we're the beneficiaries
of a lot of it because we see what he
did
and you know i saw that you know um what
he did with the movie and we were
friendly with him now and we were you
know fortunate enough to see like kind
of the way he did it
and that seems to be where creatives are
going it's like full autonomy
figuring out how to make
something and then distribute it
yeah and you could also make things now
for less money so that's right where
whereas a big production would have
costed you easy six figures now you can
kind of put something together
yeah you know not that crazy he went
high level and he spent real money
um that being said you don't have to
it depends on what you want to do and
you're right it is i mean ben you always
talk about people make things with
phones oh yeah and there's a lot of
movies shot on iphones now shut up
and some of those movies that are shot
on iphone some of our major streamers oh
yeah yeah on netflix
uh tangerine was shot on uh iphone 2016
on i think a good idea today a good idea
today with the right people man that's
all you really need that's right you
know you need somebody it's it's
actually and the generation kids the
kids are growing up in this generation
which is like
it's so interesting
you wonder what
their perspective on things is going to
be
growing up in in a world where like a
lot of the institutions that we grew up
with are becoming irrelevant
yes but there's a negative to that yeah
and the negative to that is my kids and
kids and mine you know are a little it's
spoiled in like a little almost like i
don't want to say delusional they know
but like me and stacy have to tell lucas
and sophia like what they you know like
we have like nice car like you know
their feet are up on leather and i'm
going like do you understand what my
mother drove right my mother drove like
my mother drove like a [ __ ] right you
know a jalopy [ __ ] station wagon where
you know the the shifter broke it would
start smoking right you know you know my
son said to me that he goes dad i want
you to take me fishing in panama because
he saw a [ __ ] youtube clip he wants
to go to panama fishing yeah not the
long island sound he wants me to go and
i go why panama because it's where the
best fish in the world are and it's like
well that's that's [ __ ] not reality
because i'm not dad's not going to
panama all right if dad gets that money
we're going to get out of jordan's you
would buy in panama
you'd have a factory of children making
jordan i mean my son just bought a
fishing pole that that that's like top
of the line and he doesn't fish he just
saw a video yeah so he's ordering things
and he got a private reel and then he
goes can you take me can we go to panama
so that's hilarious i don't think that
is [ __ ] funny he actually asked me
that and like stacey was like stacy goes
daddy's not taking you to panama and he
was like he will you know and you know
what to be honest i look into it but
yeah
that that's a little dilute like not
delusional but it's kids don't
understand
that like you know like i remember going
out to eat with my parents it was like
once a month or once every two months
remember you'd go and you well i don't
know what the money your parents have
but like we we you know the thing is we
didn't have much we we would eat out a
lot but it would never be
like in in my thing it was a lot of like
fast
grabby food right deli kind of like
you know my parents worked a lot it was
kind of like grabbed but those nice
dinners were few and far back what did
your parents do my father was a wine uh
salesman so he was in new york city and
he would take the train in and then like
like commercial places you run around in
restaurants with a wine bag and my
mother was a swim coach and she taught
private swim lessons and stuff so she
would start like early in the morning
and work at a pool
pretty much the whole day and then like
i spent a lot of time with my
grandparents i spent time with them too
um
but the book that's going to come out is
such a total assault on their parenting
and their lives and they're not they're
in there they're in their early 70s but
i want to get it out while they're still
here it's so important um they were they
were not they were not abusive but they
were just boomers and boomers you know a
lot of them just like it was just kind
of like
you know
you know it was not an involved
parenting in the way that like people
like you and stacy are probably a lot
more involved yeah with your kids do it
like my parents were not involved my
parents had a brutal brutal divorce when
i was five and christian my older
brother christian was ten yeah and it
was like text and like i never want to
bad mouth my parents because i feel like
at their ages they did the best yeah it
was it was it's right i think that era
like sometimes they don't you don't even
know the maybe the the it was never like
oh we're going to purposely [ __ ] them up
right but it was just like a lot of [ __ ]
went down my father when i was like
eight years old took me to see the movie
seven because he wanted to see it yeah
my yeah so that's the type of stuff
that's dude that is that's the type of
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
my father was so pissed when he took us
to roger rabbit because he wanted to see
anything you know and then it went to
goodfellas i should i shouldn't i was
young right you know but yeah so this is
like if he's like so you're saying
that's a boomer thing yeah it's a boomer
thing well because boomers i think that
one of the defining traits of their
uh generation was that or we have
terrible fathers and
it could be but i think one of the
defining traits of their generation was
that there was a little bit of
uh
you know they were not their their their
their parents knew like real struggle
and sacrifice and the boomers had a
version of that but nowhere near like my
father's life was nowhere near as hard
as my grandfather's and my mother's life
was nowhere near as hard as her mother's
life so what they were able to do is
focus a little bit more on themselves
right and part of the boomers thing was
that
you know they
you know
it was about them a little bit like my
grandparents it was not about them they
had seven kids yeah nothing was about
them um it was there's a selfishness
there's there's a there's a narcissistic
selfishness in that thing where that
you're right the grandparents didn't
have it because the grandparents were
just happy to get here yes and plant
their flag
and make that money that's right but
then their kids almost had that [ __ ] oh
we're here yeah what could i yeah yeah
and i and i think part of it was like
a lot of those people
uh
i mean to to be honest even though it
was tough and and you know they but they
had it pretty good yeah it's pretty good
if you look at
the climate of how easy it was to to get
a house
right own a house to own a car
to have these things
um much easier than it was for the
generation prior to them and a lot
easier than it is right now for people
right now it's tough
are you doing that book like is it a is
it a resentful thing or is it just more
of gay it's always funny so it's not
resentful it's always meant to be funny
but it is it is it is
you know
written in a way
that
is is i think kind of an attack
a funny attack a funny attack on what
happened to to goof on what happened in
a way but you know my parents were oh
you know the food our food the way
boomers raised their kids not all of
them but the specific boomers that i'm
talking about horrible food education a
lot of fast food a lot of like garbage
eating a lot of like we reward ourselves
with food or my mother was always
dieting so food was either like
we're rewarding ourselves we're being
bad or we're reigning it in your
mother's on her ninth diet and now we're
all eating this because whatever that is
you're eating that's right so it was
never
my my grandparents were never on diets
but yet they also were never eating big
ice cream sundaes right so there there's
there was this real extremes yeah that
the boomers because boomers were the
most marketed gener marketed two
generation my father loved commercials
he loved the budweiser frogs he loved
the fat guy ducking donuts when the
budweiser did the clydesdale commercial
after 9 11 he started crying oh yeah
my dad loved it they loved commercials
so you know they would you know if you
know any company out there from
mcdonald's to [ __ ] whatever if they
had a good commercial we were there the
next day that was the [ __ ] hateful
commercial yes remember oscar meyer yeah
that was yeah the song yeah and and the
cereals and [ __ ] dude when when
a fast food place would like advertise a
new thing my father would like like oh
let's get it i'll get it and like he'd
be and he was never like a big guy or
whatever he was not small but he was
never like really out of [ __ ] but he was
just like yeah i'll go get it and like
you know it was just one of those things
where it's like when you look back and
you go
you know
my parents they were like yeah college
you should go to college
there was never like
like the people people's you're gonna
take your kid to tour of colleges you're
probably gonna take lucas two different
schools and like show him which school
and go yeah what do you think of swan a
few you know
my parents i mean they were just like
yeah i can't go to college i guess go to
the community college like that's i grew
up yeah i grew up with like would go go
or just you know go to a state school
and it was and it was like yeah it
wasn't that they were bad people they
weren't abusive they weren't like
burning me with cigarettes they were
doing the best they kept my parents were
hippies kind of like my dad had a band
and my mom was when she was younger
really pretty with long hair and just
shell necklace and everything like that
and then they're thrown into the 80s
reaganomics only child only child
they're trying to figure it out yeah um
you know my dad's dad was a irish guy
who came to this country broke was
homeless and died a multi-millionaire uh
because he started a general contracting
business but his family would move every
time the rent was due
he was broke oh [ __ ] and he was tough
like he was a tough guy like p.a.l boxer
was a pool hustler wow like it was he
was one of the coolest guys like when my
father told me all this stuff as my
grandfather was dying
like and i told my friend ray who's on
the show all the time i said my
grandfather never mentioned that he was
like a pool hustler my father was like
he was like a deeply moral guy he was
like ashamed of that i'm like it's the
coolest thing i've ever heard you know
yeah but like he became a guy that was
like yeah i don't want to
he
worked so hard and was smart
ended up building a big house in
muttontown long island and you know
worked his ass off my grandmother's
husband died
when she was young he had an amphetamine
thing he took pills he had a heart thing
and she raised two kids on her own while
being a teacher full time they were
really tough people very religious very
catholic very involved in their
communities you know
um
and my and my my parents were
you know degenerate filth so you have
that dichotomy
no i'm kidding but no they you know my
parents just
you know they just you know they
were you know my grandparents are it's
movie lives movies you can make about
that uh my parents whom i love
created a comedian they made me very
funny yeah about because they you know i
mean we would do crazy things they would
do
crazy things yeah it's funny how i
wouldn't be a comic if what happened my
parents didn't happen that's right you
know i just you know first i moved a lot
so when i moved the way i adapted was oh
paul's funny watch him tell this story
and i get friends popular move again but
i knew that i had that skill and then
that's what and then the attention or
being able to adapt like that right was
was how you know it's funny when you
were saying like he was a hustler but
like didn't wanna the italian family's
day would lo they would say that's how
he did it yeah that's how he [ __ ] did
it yeah yeah yeah one day maybe you can
have something yeah
you could figure it out yeah yeah you
could figure it out anything you could
do yeah it's a it's a it's an issue the
book is not it's not like bitter i'm
happy with everything you know
it's just looking back at
how funny it all was and how crazy it
all was right yeah like how
like unprepared they were to have a kid
and how
oh well how could they be prepared right
i mean it's just this crazy thing and
like i was not a perfect kid either and
like
that whole thing i think is really if
you're documenting the chaos in a in a
funny way with your in the best way with
your skills
it's the chaos you know what i mean like
it's the chaos
of
a family you know they didn't love each
other yeah you know they did in the
beginning but that wore off
and then what you had is like they my
father hung out at this local steakhouse
with this just the owner of it who was
hilarious and he would go out every
thursday night to this like men's club
where all these guys were sitting
complaining about their wives and my
mother like would go to just kind of
this local diner and [ __ ] about him
yeah and he [ __ ] about her and it was
kind of funny and i'd go with one of
them one night and the other one the
other night
and um yeah it was it was uh
supremely unhealthy
[Laughter]
but funny right like but
i looked back and i go this is funny but
i'm like also like knowing what i know
i'm like this is what a crazy thing and
just you know i mean they got divorced
for two years they're divorced they
could not afford to get lawyers so they
had a mediator it would come to the
house they had nothing there was nothing
to mediate there was nothing to divide
they had nothing right and they lived
there for two years in separate bedrooms
fighting each other like the movie the
war of the roses
not even kidding and a mediator would
like come and divide beanie babies
because they had nothing like the
mediator would sit at the table and go
like well patty's getting the lamp and
my dad goes well we didn't discuss that
like yeah yeah so that's how crazy and
spiteful they were
instead of just figuring out like let's
just make a clean break it'll be good
for the kid
when did that happen when seventh grade
oh okay so and that was so it was bitter
when it was brilliant oh it was brutally
bitter and angry but they had nothing
it's one thing when rich people right
you're getting the cars you're getting
the [ __ ] man they had nothing yeah so
they're they're they're they're feeling
like people had nothing
and they would just fight about the
nothing they had
they had spent their lives attaining
nothing
and you know like it was like wait what
who did you stay with i said to my
mother for two years then i went to my
father i wasn't even part of the fight i
don't think they cared who got me you
were more concerned about like lamps and
end tables
yeah i don't think they cared like my
mother i think fought for me a little
and my dad goes great yeah and then two
years later she goes no you take them
you've been putting my foot on that
ottoman yeah
you know it was crazy so like
it was interesting yeah and um
you know it was a very boomer way to
to grow up but um you know i'm i'm
excited about
uh
hopefully putting that all together and
having that be funny and then having
people go oh i actually can relate to
that it's impossible for that to be yeah
i i went to a pizza hut lunch buffet
i i understand
uh you know i i went through some of
these things i get it too
and that's the type of uh and just
growing up in the suburbs
in that era smoking pot [ __ ] trying
to dodge your your mother's car like you
know we
we had it was a green my friend shay's
mother had a green fort taurus and
i remember that car perfectly i see it
right now i see the headlights green
ford taurus right she loved it
and the only other guy in the town that
had green ford taurus was the chinese
delivery guy right and
we were high all the time when we were
like 15 years old oh my god and we would
and we'd see the green four tours
and we're like dude we're praying we're
praying and then we just see him go by
and be like thank god he's the chinese
guy you know
we're like and like he'd be like he's
not the [ __ ] chinese guy i'm like a
chinese guy and we're like okay
so it's like those weird weird things
like that that you know yeah are just
kind of stupid and funny oh dude i
remember one time this italian kid goes
yeah dude we had nothing to do yeah and
he goes yeah dude let's go down by the
highway and throw rocks at cars yeah and
like we would [ __ ] people would yeah
like pelt [ __ ] yeah like it was the
most ridiculous insane it was insane
like like throwing i guess cars are
going 80 miles an hour yeah and and i
remember one time this cadillac came
back this cadillac of italian guys came
back and we had to just jump in this
prickers in the middle of the night down
low yeah kid's like we're gonna [ __ ] you
whoever you know the guy's walking
around with something in his head and
stuff and we're just laying in the
prickers i could have killed him yeah
could have [ __ ] it's like the dumbest
yeah you know but is it was it a simpler
like because i i look at like when i got
stranger things you watched that ever or
not yeah i watched your first season
[ __ ] seasons that that whole like
kind of i don't know dungeons and
dragons riding your bike completely
different it was completely different
uh
this has i mean this has changed ever
like there there will be
there is absolutely
no
it's almost incomparable yeah you know
growing up without this and growing up
with it
you know it's such a different time
it's almost like a car and not a car yes
it's almost like that difference it's
even worse because what not even worse
or better but like
you you basically you have this thing
that allows you
you are no there is you know we used to
get lost
we used to not know what was going on we
were we had imaginations you had to be
you know i mean the bonds you would
create with people
would be perhaps a little deeper
everything now is very transactional
very immediate and i think people's
brains are just trained to work in a
different way that whole like
that whole thing youtube.com
that whole like
going a tree house with your best
friends is sit down in indian style and
that's awesome
and now when they sit now when they sit
in a thing every kid is in a treehouse
right now run like you have to call
someone yeah your kid's in a tree house
now you have to call somebody yeah yeah
yeah they call a hostage negotiator yo
together four of them have been up there
for three hours what are they planning
yeah no
they're on the dark web ordering bullets
paulversie.com all your live dates are
up there watch your special on netflix
yeah check out the versi effect and i
also do another one that i co-host with
bill burke called anything better and
all new dates are coming we're getting a
whole new tour but go to paulversie.com
man thank you awesome very good
thanks for coming out
thank you brother